hello c'est Régine de TV 78 j'ai
rencontré bohémont flamand il a co-fondé
le temps des savoir-faire à Mareil-Marly
c'est une association où on apprend à
redécouvrir la nature alors il nous a
donné quelques conseils des techniques
de survie si jamais on se perd en pleine
forêt nous a notamment parlé de la règle
des trois qui stipulent qu'un être
humain ne peut survivre plus de 3
semaines sans manger trois jours sans
boire et 3 heures en hypothermie alors
on a commencé par ordre décroissant de
priorité à savoir l'alimentation
regardez
[Musique]
pour reconnaître un sureau noir qui est
la première plante sauvage comestible de
la journée on a le fait qu'on soit en
période de fructification qu'on est ces
espèces de
fruits qui sont regroupés en forme de
parasol on a les lentillesse sur sur les
corps on dirait presque que l'arbuste il
a il a la varicelle et puis surtout dans
le bois surtout les les jeunes tiges on
a une moelle extrêmement proéminente
dire que quand on ouvre il y a très peu
de bois il y a très peu de moi le pardon
à l'intérieur on a une espèce de on
dirait presque du polystyrène on a
quasiment que de la moelle à l'intérieur
donc si on réunit tous ces critères là
on commence à être quasi sûr qu'on a
bien devant nous un sureau noir et alors
qu'est-ce qui se mange dans ce sureau
c'est les fruits et c'est exactement ça
c'est les fruits alors il faut attendre
déjà qu'ils soient noir et une fois
qu'ils sont mûres il faut les cuire et
c'est pour ça que traditionnellement on
fait souvent des gelés des confitures
avec les fruits du sureau noir qui sont
d'ailleurs délicieuses et donc là en
situation on a besoin de manger on va
aller chercher ses fruits mûres noirs on
les cuit et là ils sont comestibles
[Musique]
une
ortie crue ça peut se manger ouais en
fait on pense toujours que l'ortie c'est
uniquement comestible cuite mais on peut
aussi tout totalement la manger crue
juste il faut mettre en place un petit
stratagème pour pas se piquer donc je
t'invite à prendre la feuille par la
base et tu tires vers l'extrémité donc
tu peux le faire par exemple sur celle
là
voilà super et tu vas déjà dans un
premier temps tu peux caresser la
feuille de la base vers le sommet
voilà c'est ça exactement et ensuite tu
vas faire des pliages donc tu fais un
premier pliage de la feuille sous la
longueur et à chaque fois que tu fais un
pliage tu vas compresser en même temps
tu peux le faire trois quatre fois si tu
es pas tout à fait sereine de le manger
directement et après une fois que tu as
bien neutralisé ses poils urticants là
tu peux la mettre en bouche et la manger
donc l'idée de plier c'est vraiment pour
éviter de se piquer exactement et tu vas
voir cru c'est un goût complètement
différent que quand on cuit l'ortie
c'est un goût presque de concombre
c'est parti
ah oui
là je sens le goût du concombre c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
et donc le noisetier qui fait des
noisettes des noisettes effectivement
c'est parmi les arbustes les plus
caloriques qu'on puisse trouver dans nos
régions parce que 100 g de noisettes
c'est plus de 600 kcal ce qui est énorme
sachant que il faut par jour à peu près
2000 en moyenne
pour donner un ordre de grandeur de
comparaison la laitue pour 100 g donc
pour la même quantité car entre 10 et 20
kcal donc on voit qu'en terme d'énergie
surtout dans une configuration comme la
nôtre de potentiel survie on a besoin
d'énergie là la noisette ça va quand
même être un élément de choix et c'est
pour ça que le Nutella c'est une bombe
calorique parce qu'on a du sucre on a de
l'huile on a du chocolat et on a des
noisettes avec pour 100 g plus de 600
kcal et si je suis perdue dans la nature
et que j'ai envie de manger des
noisettes comment je m'y prends comme ça
et c'est à quel moment aussi que je peux
les
les cueillir puisque là je vois qu'elles
sont pas du tout mûres alors là on y est
presque
à peu près dans un mois ça va commencer
à être vraiment mature après ça dépend
des années mais globalement c'est plutôt
fin août qu'on commence à avoir des
belles noisettes faut vite les manger
parce que les écureuils sont quand même
un peu un peu vorace mais ensuite il
suffit de les ouvrir et on peut manger
directement la noisette à l'intérieur on
peut les faire cuire on peut les manger
cru
[Musique]
alors tu te souviens au début on n'avait
pas à manger et maintenant on va passer
à l'étape on n'a pas à boire ce qui est
beaucoup plus urgent parce que tu te
rappelles trois semaines sans manger 3
jours sans boire donc c'est beaucoup
plus court terme comme problématique
alors là devant nous on a de l'eau et
souvent dans les différentes sources
d'eau qu'on peut trouver il y a deux
contaminations potentielles la première
qui est une contamination plus de
l'ordre du vivant bactériologique et la
deuxième contamination qui est chimique
la première contamination
bactériologique on va plutôt s'en
débarrasser en portant l'eau à
ébullition et la deuxième on va ajouter
par exemple de l'argile ou du charbon
[Musique]
alors pour allumer un feu bohémon à
utiliser la technique par friction à
l'archet elle consiste à frotter deux
bouts de bois pour réussir à faire un
charbon incandescent qu'on va ensuite
mettre dans de la paille et qu'on va
oxygéner en soufflant et ensuite ça
devrait prendre feu alors en théorie ça
paraît simple mais en réalité ça
nécessite énormément de pratiques
d'entraînement et de connaissances sur
les matériaux utilisés
[Musique]